In the last lecture we talked about Taylor versus Caldwell and the doctrine of
impossibility where performance is excused because the duty can no longer be
physically perform.
Today we'll learn about a related doctrine,
the doctrine of frustration of purpose,
where performance is excused even if performance is physically possible because
the buyer's purpose for which the promise was originally entered into is no
longer attainable.
We do this by looking at a 1903 English case called Krill versus Henry in Krill.
The plaintiff Krill owned an apartment from which the coronation pres procession
of King Edward the seventh was visible.
The defendant Henry contracted to rent the apartment from Crowl on the day of
the precession and paid a 25 pound deposit.
However,
the king fell ill and the coronation was postponed.
Henry refused to pay the remaining balance and eh,
uh,
of the contracted rent,
which was 50 pounds.
Krell sued for this remaining balance and Henry counter sued for the original
deposit pack.
The trial court found for the defendant Henry.
The instinct court affirmed with regard to the remaining balance and it did not
decide the counter claim which was withdrawn by Henry.
The central issue is this was the coronation and implied condition proceeded for
the rental contract and the court answered yes.
The court held that the postponement of the coronation defeated the understood
purpose of the contract,
which was to license the flat and in a Hanzt rent for the purpose of viewing the
coronation.
The court began by referencing the doctrine of impossibility by quoting Taylor
versus Caldwell where the court said that if the parties understand that the
completion of a contract requires the continued existence of some particular
specified thing,
then the contract is not to be considered a positive contract,
but as subject to an implied condition that the parties shall be excused in
case,
uh,
before breach performance becomes impossible from the perishing of the thing.
So does the doctrine of impossibility,
excuse defendant from paying the balance of the rent in Krell versus Henry?
The answer's no.
The defendant contracted to rent an apartment from plaintiff,
though the royal procession was cancelled.
This did not make performance impossible.
The plaintiff was still physically able to supply the room that the defendant
contracted to rent and uh,
and the defendant could still pay.
This,
however,
did not stop the court.
The court held that the principle underlying Taylor versus Caldwell is not
limited to quote cases in which the event causing the impossibility of
performance is the destruction or nonexistence of some thing which is the
subject matter of the contract or if some condition or state of things expressly
specified as a condition of it.
The court expanded the principal to the underlying purpose of the contract
saying that one must first ascertain the substance of the contract and then ask
whether the contract needs for its foundation,
the assumption of the existence of,
of a particular state of things.
The court concluded that the use of the rooms was let and taken for the purpose
of seeing the royal possession.
That purpose was frustrated by the postponement and therefore the defendant's
breach was excused.
The reasoning relied upon by the court in Krell versus Henry has come to be
known as the frustration of purpose doctrine.
Section two 65 of the restatement describes the doctrine as follows,
where after a contract is made,
a party's principal purpose is substantially frustrated without his fault by the
occurrence of an event than non occurrence of which was a basic assumption on
which the contract was made.
His remaining duties to render performance or discharged,
unless the language of the circumstances indicate the contrary in another famous
but much older English case.
The court treated frustration of purpose very differently.
In Paradigm v Jane decided in 1647 the defendant rented land from the plaintiff.
However,
Prince Rupert of Germany invaded and took the land for three years during the
English civil war and the defendant did not pay rent during that time.
The plaintiff sued for the rent owed,
but the defendant claimed that he owed nothing because of the invasion had
frustrated his purpose in rendering the land,
which the purpose was to a possession.
The court held that the defendant was not excused from paying the rent.
Among other reasons,
the court reasoned that quote,
as the lessee is to have the advantage of casual profits.
So he must run the hazard of casual losses unquote.
In other words,
if the plaintiff is able to retain the unexpected benefits from renting the land
such as a bumper harvest,
the plaintiffs should also bear the unexpected losses.
How would the court and Krell versus Henry respond to this policy argument?
For example,
what would happen if instead of the coronation a decided to give a free concert
underneath the balcony on the day that Henry rented the apartment,
the lease hold might be worth more under this circumstance,
but the lessee wouldn't have to pay more
in Krell versus Henry Henry paid a $25 25 pound deposit in advance and
counterclaim for its return.
The lower court held that Henry was entitled to the return of his deposit,
but Henry withdrew this counter claim on appeal,
perhaps to bolster his case by rep representing the deposit as part of
liquidated damages forfeited on his breach.
So the king's bench did not have to review the trial court's holding,
uh,
on appeal about the return of the deposit.
But in other coordination cases,
the plaintiffs sought and were denied restitution of the death of their down
payments.
The gains and losses were left were the,
they lay at the time of the frustration.
Impracticability is about increases in sellers costs of performing promises,
whereas frustration is centrally about decreases in buyers benefits when
unexpected events occur that either increase the seller's cost or decrease the
buyer's benefit.
Courts sometimes discharge the party's duty to perform,
but doctrines are both.
Doctrines are ways that courts make promises that seem unconditional on their
face to be conditioned by default on the seller's performance,
not becoming impracticable or the buyer's benefit from performance not being
frustrated by discharging performance.
When these bad news events occur,
these doctrines spread the risk of the bad news between the two contractors.
In Taylor,
it'd be adding insult to injury for the law to force the landlord to pay damages
on top of losing his music.
Call to fire their reluctance to have landlords in Krill disgorge.
The rent deposit might be a rough way to spread risk of the bad news of
coronation delay between the landlord and the tenant.
By the way,
the law treats opportunity costs very differently than costs.
A seller who faces dramatically higher opportunity cost of performance will not
have her promise discharge.
Imagine that Rockefeller had offered to pay the landlord $1 million to rent the
apartment for the coronation.
The landlord's opportunity costs of renting to the initial renter would be
dramatically higher because of Rockefellers offer,
but the landlord would be liable for damages if he breached in forcing the
contract.
In response to good news of a competitive offer is a way of spreading the good
news risk by encouraging landlords to compensate the previous tenant for being
displaced.
The doctrines of frustration and impracticability may be circumstances where the
law is driven as much by conceptions of equity as conceptions of efficiency.
Let's recap.
Today we learned about the frustration of purpose doctrine.
According to the frustration of purchase doc purpose doctrine.
Nonperformance of a contract may be excused if the purpose for which the parties
entered into the contract as frustrated by an event that was not contemplated by
the parties at the time of the contract.